and local leaders are ramping up efforts
to get those vaccines to those who need
it the most
the mexican consulate hosting its first
vaccine clinic
they distributed 250 vaccines to people
who were 65 years and older
sally jaramillo has been talking to some
people who waited today to get more
information and she joins us now live
sally brian and denise it was a very
busy day here at the mexican
consulate now the many latinos i spoke
to today tell me
they were a bit nervous to get the
vaccine but after they got it
they felt a huge relief and tonight they
want to encourage
everyone to get vaccinated very easy
very easy martin kevin hoffman just
received the first dose of a vaccine i
had my appointment at 10 o'clock in the
morning i got
arrived at 10 o'clock and i went in
immediately
and i was out in 20 minutes ken hoffman
says after talking to his brother
a doctor in mexico and a friend
referring him to the mexican consulate
he decided to make the appointment it's
going to help me
keep my health in good shape in case i
will get the computer
which is a possibility it will be not so
so hard on me i think the government is
doing a good job
they're trying very hard it's a lot of
people and
i think it's becoming more and more
common
as for the process he says it was easy
and staff
helpful everybody is very kind and they
are very careful
very clean kevin hoffman tells me he
felt no pain
and did not get sick after i think it's
an opportunity it's a gift
that we are receiving and we shouldn't
let it go
diana de pablo brought her mother to get
vaccinated
i feel more comfortable for my mom
because she feels
calm and optimistic optimistic
that this could end the pandemic don't
be scared
and safe and this better protect
our community
a reminder there is no cost for the
vaccine and they will not ask you
any immigration questions reporting live
sally caramillo 8 news now